MVP ROOKIE OF THE YEAR.
WILL IT BE ANTHONY HALLIBURTON
OR CHARLOTTE'S LA MEL LOVE BALL?
>> MY BOY JUST WON ROOKIE OF THE
YEAR, BUT HE DON'T KNOW IT YET.
WATCH THIS.
NICE, AIN'T IT?
I THINK HE COMING.
HOLD ON.
>> I AIN'T GOING TO LIE, THE
WORKOUT WAS DOING ME TODAY.
HAD ME SHOOTING A LOT, PLAYING A
LOT.
WEIGHT ROOM, SO YEAH, IT WAS A
GREAT DAY AT WORK, A GREAT DAY
AT PRACTICE.
>> THANKS.
>> THREE-POINTERS, COULD BE
HARD.
IT'S LOOKING COOL.
EMBIID DUNKS, THOUGH, HARD.
I NEED THE DUNKS LIKE MINE.
>> THE BIG QUESTION, IF YOU'RE
GOING TO RUN THE NBA JAM WHICH
OF THE DUOS YOU GOING WITH?
>> YOU KNOW.
YOU AIN'T GOT TO ASK THAT
QUESTION.
>> YOU ALREADY KNOW, GANG.
AH!
YOU FEEL ME?
>> YOU MESS WITH THIS SHIRT FOR
REAL?
>> YES.
>> YOU MESS WITH THIS ONE, BRO?
>> OH, THAT'S HARD.
NO, THAT'S TOUGH.
>> IT'S TOUGH?
>> WHAT ABOUT THIS, GAME?
>> I TOLD HIM -- I TOLD HIM, LET
ME TAKE SOMETHING HOME.
THEY WON'T LET ME TAKE SOMETHING
HOME.
>> YOU'RE NOT EVEN LOOKING.
>> OH [ BLEEP ]
>> ROOKIE OF THE YEAR, BROTHER.
ROOKIE OF THE YEAR, BRO.
CONGRATS, BRO.
>> BRO THIS, SHIRT HARD, THOUGH.
>> HEA